what's your favorite musical number or
choreography can you even think of that
that bar bag
I can't it's hard to pick you know it's
hard to pick a single moment when we
film the number heavy boobs to
demonstrate what I wanted a piece of
blocking to be I was braless at a
choreography rehearsal and my
choreographer Catherine for our
choreographer Catherine burns who's here
was like show me what you mean by if I
swung them in your face you'd be like oh
my god that hurts and so there was a
slow-mo video of me at Kats request to
demonstrate a dance move with my braless
bosom hitting her in the face and you
see her slow-mo her cheek just go no and
it's great the most difficult was
probably the tango we did the tango
season 3 that that took a long time to
get right I've never tangled the fourth
I wanna fight it's like a week in the
app is the longest we spent on I spent
on a number anyway but it's probably
angry but as far as fun the what's it
called I can't think of the name of the
song now it's giving me but in season
three and we all dress like hair like we
all had the white shirts and the red
hearts Oh without love you can save the
world that's what it's going use achill
numbers and choreography is such a big
part of the show we have a favorite one
out of all of the season my favorites
was California Christmas time because it
was the first time that I had this dance
choreography in my life
everybody else all these other people
all from Broadway and they're all like
okay would you show it to me yeah okay
got it
my wife had that we had to film it and
then do it in five second increments so
I'd be like and then at my right foot
right and then I would do it on oh my
god cuz when you're doing choreography
it's got to be good for everybody so if
I'm lame that ruins to take for
everybody's hating my favorite
choreography was strip away
that's Fosse number I mean I had my huge
Fosse fan but I think cat burns our
choreographer Emmy winning choreographer
I think she really nailed it and I think
Rachel looked great and I thought was
the perfect match of song and
choreography strip it
[Music]
that was just up my butt is there one
that stands out in your mind there is
one in our series finale that it's so
musical theater
it's very conical and the cats that is
able to be brought together into this
number is really a last hurrah moment so
not only is it beautiful to see in so
colorful
but we are dancing our booties off we
are singing we're throwing props all in
the air and it's an it's in a location
that everyone is familiar with it you've
never seen it in this element before and
we had a lot of guest stars that were
able to dance and sing with us so we
were able to kind of like have a summer
theater camp moment at the end our final
final episode and save at the moment all
together